♪ ♪
>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
IT’S A CONGRESSIONAL STOCK
SCANDAL COME UP FOR U.S.
SENATOR IS NOW UNDER FIRE FOR
SELLING OFF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF STOCK IN THE DAYS BEFORE THE
CORONAVIRUS CRASHED THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
DEMOCRAT DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND
REPUBLICANS RICHARD BURR, KELLY
LOEFFLER AND JAMES INHOFE ALL
DUMPED ASSETS FOLLOWING A
REPORTEDLY CLASSIFIED ALL
SENATORS BRIEFING AT THE END
OF JANUARY.
NOW ALL FOUR OF THE CENTERS ARE
DENYING ANY WRONGDOING AND
SENATOR BURR IS CALLING FOR AN
ETHICS REVIEW OF HIS OWN ACTION.
SENATOR LOEFFLER WAS GRILLED
THIS MORNING BY FOX’S ED HENRY
ON "AMERICA’S NEWSROOM."
>> YOU THOUGHT THE GOVERNOR WAS
PREPARED BUT SHORTLY AFTER THAT
TWEET YOU SOLD A MILLION DOLLARS
IN STOCKS IN YOUR OWN PERSONAL
PORTFOLIO BEFORE THE MARKET WENT
DOWN.
YOU TRADING ON INSIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WAS
COMING?
>> I’M REALLY GLAD YOU ASKED
BECAUSE I WANT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT.
I’VE SEEN SOME OF THOSE STORIES,
AND IT’S ABSENTLY FALSE AND
COULD NOT BE TRUE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PERSONAL
TRANSACTION REPORTS WERE FILED
YOUR NOTICE AT THE BOTTOM THAT
I’M ONLY INFORMED OF THOSE
TRANSACTIONS AFTER THEY OCCUR
SEVERAL WEEKS.
>> Juan: IT’S HARD TO MAKE
SENSE OF ALL OF THIS.
LET ME START BY ASKING YOU, IS
THIS SERIOUS?
IN THE LOEFFLER CASE IT’S ALSO
AN ISSUE THAT NOT ONLY DOES SHE
SELL STUFF, BUT SHE BOUGHT STUFF
AND ONE OF THE ITEMS SHE BOUGHT
WAS TO HELP PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
WORK AT HOME, SOFTWARE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: IT LOOKS REALLY BAD
IT, ALL FOUR OF THEM HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF SKETCHINESS.
I WILL START WITH THE LEAST,
IMHOFF SAID HE WAS NEVER MOVING
BEFORE THE VIRUS.
HE SOLD THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
STOCK.
FEINSTEIN SAYS IT WAS A PLANE
TRUST, IT WAS MY HUSBAND’S
DOING.
I WASN’T EVEN AT THE BRIEFING ON
THE VIRUS AND IT WAS JUST ONE
COMPANY.
BUT IT WAS $6 MILLION IN A
BIOTECH COMPANY AND WE DON’T
REALLY KNOW MUCH ELSE ABOUT THAT
THAT.
NOW LOEFFLER IS THE HUSBAND OF
THE NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE AND
SHE SOLD THESE STOCKS ON THE DAY
OF THE BRIEFING.
RIGHT AFTER IT HAPPENED.
AND NOT ONLY DID SHE SELL A LOT
OF STOCK SHE BOUGHT STOCK THAT
BENNETT’S BENEFITS FROM SOFTWARE
THAT HELPS TELEWORKING.
PERFECTLY TIMED RICHARD BURR
LIQUIDATED ALMOST HIS ENTIRE
PORTFOLIO.
HE HAS ALL THE INTEL BECAUSE HE
IS THE TOP INTEL GUY ON THE
SENATE AND HE WAS TELLING PEOPLE
PRIVATELY THAT THIS PANDEMIC WAS
GOING TO BE AS BAD AS THE 1918
SPANISH FLU PANDEMIC.
ALSO PERFECTLY TIMED IT RIGHT
FOR THE MARKET DROPPED AND HE
SAID, I TRADED IT BEFORE BECAUSE
I SAW SOME NEWS ON CNBC.
I THINK EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED AND TREATED FAIRLY
BUT A REALLY BAD LOOK.
>> Juan: EMILY, SENATOR BURR
SAYS SIMPLY, IT WASN’T MY
ACTIONS EVEN IF YOU WERE TO TRY
TO PUT THEM TOGETHER.
THE FACT IS, HE SAYS, HE HAD NO
SPECIAL INTELLIGENCE EVEN THOUGH
HE’S THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
HE SAID EVERYTHING HE DID WAS
BASED ON PUBLIC REPORTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> RIGHT.
HE SAID I ONLY LISTEN TO HIS
CNBC COVERING THE ASIAN MARKETS.
IN MY OPINION TO GO OFF OF
JESSE’S RANKING OF THE OUTLAWS
COME AT THE TOP TWO ARE THE
WORST AND SENATOR BURR’S IS THE
WORST BY FAR.
HIS REPORTED NET WORTH TWO YEARS
AGO WAS 1.7 RIGHT MILLION.
THIS IS BETWEEN
600,001.7 MILLION.
HIS DISPARITY BETWEEN HIS
PUBLIC-PRIVATE COMMENTS AND HIS
VOTE IN 2012 AGAINST A RULING
CONGRESS BANNING INSIDER TRADING
OBVIOUS HE RAISES A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
AND HER REPORTED NET WORTH IS
500 MILLION IN THE MOST SHE
REPORTEDLY SOLD OFF WAS
3.1 MILLION.
SO THAT’S LESS THAN 1%.
SHE SAID I DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT IT,
LEARNED ABOUT IT WEEKS AFTER.
FEINSTEIN SAYS IT’S A BLIND
TRUST SO WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Juan: GREG, I KNOW YOU ARE
NORMALLY A SKEPTIC AND PUBLIC
OFFICIALS SOMETIMES ANGER YOU SO
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT THIS
THIS?
>> Greg: I AM MORE UPSET I
GUESS THAT ALL OF THEM FOR NOT
KNOWING MORE ABOUT THE ISSUE IN
GENERAL.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
JESSE AND EMILY SAID ABOUT THE
LEVELS OF GUILT.
BUT I’M KIND OF TICKED OFF.
WHAT DATE WAS THAT MEETING?
END OF JANUARY END OF FEBRUARY?
>> Juan: THAT WAS RIGHT WHEN
THE PRESIDENT WAS SHUTTING DOWN
TRAVEL.
>> Greg: SHE COULD ARGUE THAT
SHE HAD MISSED IT.
BUT THE THING IS -- TWO THINGS.
I’M MORE UPSET THAT THESE PEOPLE
WERE NOT ON THE BALL TWO OR
THREE WEEKS EARLIER AND COULD
HAVE ACTED MORE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAN THEIR STOCK
PORTFOLIO.
BUT I’M ALSO JUST TICKED OFF IN
GENERAL AT THE STOCK MARKET AND
THE INSTABILITY AND FRANTIC
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE.
TODAY IT SWUNG FROM 800 UP, TO
900 DOWN.
I FEEL LIKE I’M AROUND A DRUNK
DRIVING DOWN THE
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD.
IT’S LIKE CAN WE DRUG THE STOCK
MARKET, IT CAN WAIT DRUGGED THEM
FOR A MONTH AND PUT THEM TO
SLEEP AND WAKE THEM UP WHEN IT’S
OVER?
>> Juan: IT’S A
ROLLER COASTER.
WHAT STRUCK ME IS THIS REPORT,
BARRY WAS AT A PUBLIC LUNCHEON
AND HE SAID THIS IS GOING TO BE
LIKE THE 19-18 PANDEMIC.
HOW CAN HE NOW SAY HE DIDN’T
KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO COME?
>> Dana: HE WROTE AN OP-ED
PIECE SAYING BASICALLY THE U.S.
IS PREPARED.
UP UNTIL 2012 INSIDER TRADING,
IT’S NOT EVEN ILLEGAL.
IT WAS FUNNY BUSINESS GOING ON
SO THERE WAS THIS LOSS.
SO THE STOCK LOSS COMES INTO
PLAY AND HERE’S THE THING.
THE CONGRESSMAN FROM UPSTATE
NEW YORK WHO MAKES -- IT SENDS
THE TEXT MESSAGE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THE SOUTH LAWN
WHERE THEY ARE HAVING A
CONGRESSIONAL PICNIC TELLING HIS
FAMILY, AND THEY GET CAUGHT.
HERE’S WHAT I WOULD DO.
IF I WERE EVER GOING TO BE A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, I WOULD WANT
TO NOT KNOW.
I WOULD WANT TO PUT IT IN A
BLIND TRUST DID NOT EVEN HAVE
THE POSSIBILITY OF PERCEPTION.
IF THIS ENDS ANY CAREERS IT’S A
TERRIBLE LEGACY.
>> Juan: NOW THAT YOU’VE SAID
IT, I DON’T KNOW WHAT I’M GOING